[Music]
welcome to each person here you honor us
today with your presence the invocation
will now be given by rabbi Daniel cheb
its chaplain and MIT
it's customary at these occasions for
the speaker to address his or her words
to the Lord with a wishful ambition of
being overheard by the company present
since this expectation is of dubious
merit I prefer to address my invocation
to the company with the sure and certain
knowledge that it will be overheard by
the Almighty and so honored guests it is
to our new precedent that our hopes and
prayers are directed today president
vest some 2,000 years ago a
distinguished young rabbi named Eliezer
was elected president of the Jewish
college called the great Sanhedrin in
Jerusalem decades later commenting on
his career the talmud reports that even
though Rabbi Eliezer
achieved high academic office
nonetheless he lived a long life I'm
sure you can sympathize with that rabbi
the mantle of leadership cannot always
be worn without pain permit me to
commend to you the advice a Hasidic
master gave to his disciples a couple
hundred years ago he was asked by one of
them rabbi why do we have two pockets in
our pants they serve a lofty purpose he
replied every man must keep two pieces
of paper one in each pocket to be
retrieved as necessary in one pocket the
piece of paper must read the world was
created only for my sake but in the
other pocket the slip of paper should
read quoting the biblical patriarch
Abraham behold I am but dust and ashes
this is more than pious advice it's good
planning
on the one hand do not think that all
problems are comprehensible let alone
solvable though the women and men at
this great institution spend their days
creating ideas and theories and books
and even new forms of life we need to
remind ourselves that we are but
creatures ourselves somewhat frail and
often vulnerable and badly in need of
the love and forbearance that we can
give to each other do not let this be a
place where human failure is inexcusable
or where the search for excellence
becomes a thin disguise for moral
solipsism let us learn humility from the
grandeur of the world which we conspire
to conquer every day on the other hand
remember please that long ago God took
the mantle of authority from prophets
and placed it on the shoulders of wise
administrators this is a huge juggernaut
of an institution divided into many
departments and offices and functions
with many rules and procedures which
bureaucracy requires it takes knowledge
and skill to navigate through it
successfully but it takes wisdom to know
when to rise above it all you have
scores of advisers who can tell you what
is necessary or inevitable or required
or state or federally mandated but only
you can decide when rules must be broken
in order to do what is right every time
an undergraduate is ignored by an
overworked TA every time a grad student
is abused by a disinterested supervisor
every time a faculty member is unjustly
denied tenure their cries will go unto
God and God will hear them but before
those cries and petitions reached the
celestial throne of God they will
undoubtedly land on your desk
what happens next will make a great deal
of difference to this Institute and for
this nation in a culture beset by the
constant pressure to produce results
when young students need not only good
teachers but good models you can make
the system work centuries ago the Bible
recalls young king saul attempted to
excuse his lack of leadership by
complaining that the popular will was
against him scolding him for his
acquiescence to moral compromise the
prophet Samuel thundered though you be
small in your own eyes behold you are
the leader of these many tribes in so
president vest we ask for you God's
gifts of humility and boldness of
forbearance and strength of character of
cunning and of wisdom may you learn to
use these gifts wisely and appropriately
may God give them not just for you but
so that you can share them with us and
oh yes may you always be prepared on
short notice to put your hands in your
pockets
thank you Dan now this morning we
engaged in the formal portion of this
signal day so important than the life
and history of this University and now
we continue with no less formal with
less formal but no less warm events in
preparation for this day I must tell you
chuck I looked up in Webster's the
definition of vest the second meaning of
that transitive verb is and I quote to
grant or endow with a particular
authority right or property and the
quote now that's reasonably descriptive
of what we're up to today although I
must tell you Chuck that no endowment
goes with it we do indeed vest Chuck and
Becky with all the rights and
responsibilities joys tribulations
satisfactions and heartburn that go with
that partnership that comprises the
presidency and we do so with the light
and confidence a confidence ratified by
your presence with us since last October
we are joined by friends and associates
who will bring their own personal
messages to the vests at this luncheon
we will hear next from William F weld
governor of the state of Massachusetts
an ex-officio a member of the
Institute's governing board he will
bring greetings from the Commonwealth
following governor weld we will hear
from Derek Bok president of Harvard
University who will bring greetings on
behalf of our sister institutions in
Cambridge and Greater Boston and then
from Professor Henry D Jacoby chairman
of the MIT faculty who will bring
greetings on behalf of his colleagues at
MIT governor weld
[Applause]
thank you very much I am honored to be
here today to celebrate with you a new
beginning for MIT and to welcome to
Massachusetts a man whose talent and
commitment to education and the
advancement of engineering and life
sciences runs deep your new president
Chuck vest president vest when you
agreed to become the president of MIT a
year ago you took on an awesome
responsibility
you agreed to steer the school that
leads the country in scientific
innovation and entrepreneurship MIT
alumni have founded more than 600
companies in this state Raytheon digital
Tara Dean and Apollo computer to name
just a few firms spawned by MIT are
spread over a hundred and four cities
and towns hear and employ more than
300,000 people generating more than 10
billion dollars in income throughout the
state those are the kinds of numbers
that these degenerate days I like to
hear I understand that MIT hackers are
quick enough to have already pulled a
prank or two in your office and aren't
doing too poorly in the research area
either seriously the creativity and
entrepreneurial energy of MIT students
faculty and alumni have led to the
development of high tech computers and
high-definition television they've
improved the capabilities of the Patriot
missile and found better ways to
candy-coat MMS I have five children who
want to know how they can get in on that
project I do believe that institutions
like MIT will be the key to the new
growth so badly needed in this state
they can put the people of Massachusetts
back to work and help make Massachusetts
a hub of international trade in fact if
we do not soon see a turnaround in the
economy of Massachusetts mr. president
I'm going to
referring the press inquiries to you
there's nothing more essential for
economic recovery than human capital and
we will be looking to academic
institutions like MIT for their
invaluable leadership in that area and
if there are any other academic
institutions of the caliber of MIT in
the Cambridge Boston area that are
brought to our attention we will look to
them as well
[Applause]
president vest has proven himself to be
a true leader as provost and Dean of
engineering at the University of
Michigan and he is by common consensus
the right man to lead MIT into the 21st
century
mr. president I look forward to working
with you as a fellow rookie together to
help make Massachusetts the glittering
capitol of the Atlantic Rim thank you
very much
[Applause]
present best Sendak ND governor weld
honored guests it's a great pleasure to
be here once again to bring greetings on
behalf of the area's universities you
are mister vest the fourth president of
MIT whom I've been a privilege to have
as a colleague and this is the third MIT
inauguration that I have attended and
these occasions always inspire me to
think back on the halcyon days around
the turn of the century when Harvard was
already a quarter of a millennium old
and MIT but a small struggling back Bay
institution four times Harvard tried to
envelop MIT in its smothering embrace
and each time some stubborn obstacle got
in the way first it was a recalcitrant
MIT president with his impractical ideas
about independence and then there was a
mob of angry alumni who thought they
knew better than a willing MIT president
and trustees and finally after
everything else was settled a small
matter of a dowry intervened a judge
ruled that MIT could not sell its Back
Bay mansion and give the proceeds to
Harvard and at that moment as in a great
Shakespearean tragedy at the very moment
that success was at hand
Harvard's ambitions were thwarted by one
tiny flaw our overweening preoccupation
with money well history will be the
judge of these misadventures but up the
river I want to tell you some of us are
beginning to wonder whether your alumni
might not have been right after all you
do seem to be doing extraordinarily well
on your own I know that because US News
and World Report just informed me that
MIT ranks number one in engineering
while Harvard
stood 22nd actually both of us were
delighted MIT of course was pleased to
be number one and since Harvard doesn't
have an engineering school we were very
pleased to be recognized at all
[Applause]
an MIT inauguration is always an
important event for higher education
because MIT is such an important
institution the flagship of America's
academic science engineering and
technology and today mr. vest as you
know and as you will be told repeatedly
you stride upon that particular deck at
a very critical moment in the life of
science and technology in this country
because certainly not in my lifetime has
there been such a precarious difficult
time to captain that particular vessel
our universities do lead the world in
their overall quality and yet
paradoxically academic science is the
subject of attack from many quarters
well referred to by you and president
roads this morning there is of course a
kernel of truth in all of these attacks
that must be faced and dealt with
there's also a lot of exaggeration and
misunderstanding and much more important
a great deal of preoccupation with
relatively minor scandals while major
problems go unattended that will
ultimately shape our scientific future
and so confronted with such problems we
have need of eloquent spokesmen to
explain and to interpret ourselves in
Washington and elsewhere but much more
important we need able representatives
who will work with their serious
counterparts in the halls of government
to establish what a real agenda should
be to rebuild our tattered partnership
and to decide what needs to be done to
keep our academic science at the
forefront almost half a century ago a
small group of scientists and statesmen
began to dream and plan to make the
quality of American Science and
Technology the greatest in the world
the work began in the administration of
and with the blessing of a Harvard man
Franklin Delano Roosevelt it was
conceived and described most brilliantly
by a professor from MIT Vannevar Bush
and it is your responsibility now mr.
best to help once again to lay the plans
that will keep our science preeminent
for yet another generation all of us who
care about higher education and the
welfare of this country wish you every
success in that great task thank you
[Applause]
governor weld senator Kennedy
distinguished guests and friends Chuck
and Becky our guests here may not
realize it but in the ceremony in which
you participated this morning you can
already see the beginning of the
commitment that Chuck spoke about in his
address as he indicated MIT has a great
concern for the productivity and
competitive competitiveness of the
United States which leads naturally for
to a focus on quality control and you
may have noticed that although this is
the inauguration he's already been the
president for seven months and we offer
to our guests from other universities
this new MIT policy which we would
suggest you we will inaugurate no
presidents before their time I've also
had several questions from people about
how it is that we pull off this trick
that the Sun gradually comes out as the
president speaks this is a specialty of
our Department of Earth atmospheric and
Planetary Sciences and I suggest you
contact them directly on behalf of the
faculty I want to extend our welcome to
those of you who've come to help us
celebrate we celebrate ourselves as MIT
we honor and celebrate those scholars
and leaders that have brought us to this
point we celebrate our collective lives
as scholars and teachers and we
celebrate Chuck and Becky I would
address Chuck and Becky you are terrific
my colleagues and I are enthusiastic
we're ready to work with you with mark
and your team to follow your lead and
shaping the future of this great
institution as chair of the faculty I
think I listen to this speech today
perhaps with somewhat different ears
than others point after point in this
speech contained not only Chuck's ideas
but ideas that have been have been
exposed winnowed in the discussion with
the community
backed by work to build consensus about
how we want to move
we're honor what we are we are on our
way I believe it's an exciting moment
for us all
[Applause]
governor wells
president Bach professor Jacobi thank
you very much will now continue with the
main course
thank you at this moment between the
main course and a solid course we will
hear greetings from two other guests
today
the first is Edward M Kennedy senior
senator from the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts
who will bring greetings from government
the second is niara Sood our casa
president of lincoln university who will
bring greetings on behalf of the
nation's historically black colleges and
universities
[Applause]
I'm honored to be with all of you and to
participate in the inauguration of
President vest in my line of work I
haven't been invited to any presidential
inaugurations lately so I'm particularly
glad to be here today
president Elliot of Harvard used to say
the reason universities are such great
storehouses of learning is that every
entering student brings a little
knowledge in and no graduating student
ever takes any knowledge out but that's
certainly not true at MIT this and the
other great private research
universities are uniquely American
creations and they are matched nowhere
else in the world most often we think of
MIT in terms of engineering electronics
and computer sciences but beyond the
worlds of engineering and computer
science you're also renowned for your
pioneering work in public health and the
biological sciences and in economics and
the social sciences as well MIT
researchers achieve the first synthesis
of penicillin you have led the fight
against cancer with path-breaking
studies of the cell's nucleus and today
it has fairly said that MIT has the
finest biology department in the world
if MIT were for sale every other nation
in the world plus 49 other states would
want to buy it regardless of the price
what happens in research universities is
also a major concern for government
because of the increasing national need
for highly trained sophisticated
workforce the federal government has
long sought to increase the supply of
graduate level scientists and engineers
last year Congress enacted legislation
that will more than double the number of
federally sponsored graduate fellowships
by 1993 in recent years mit has had more
of these fellowship winners than any
other institution in the nation to help
students and families meet the high cost
of education the federal government has
created a broad range of student aid
programs together these initiatives now
provide more than 18 billion dollars a
year for tuition later this year
Congress will reauthorize the Higher
Education Act you don't often read about
it in the headlines but it may
the most important measure we enact this
year for the long run future of our
country and I look forward to working
with president vest and many of you here
to ensure that this legislation is
worthy of the challenges we face the
level of public investment in scientific
research is also a matter of growing
concern every official knows we are
living in the Golden Age of science in
spite of the successes of the past and
because of the budget pressures of the
present universities find themselves
under intense scrutiny and harsh
criticism today much of it fair but some
of it not so concerns about the
escalating cost of education scientific
fraud and waste student loan to false
and the imbalance between teaching and
research have all begun to tarnish the
reputation of higher education frankly I
suspect president vest wishes he had not
just an engineering degree but a CPA as
well and if the battles get any rougher
he may want a bulletproof vest also
neither government officials nor private
universities can deal with these
challenges alone we must all work harder
together not just to resolve these
concerns but resolve them fairly and
resolve them expeditiously only in this
way can we revitalize the extraordinary
partnership between government and
research universities that has served
this nation so well for the past 50
years finally as night follows day as
more and more public dollars are
invested in education more and more
accountability to the public will
inevitably inevitably be required our
job once again it can only be done
together is to maximize the clarity of
whatever regulation is needed minimize
the bureaucracy and above all minimize
the intrusion by government into
academic life and work in achieving
these goals the nation will need strong
leadership in science policy the kind
that we have had in the past from James
Killian Jerome Wiesner guy stiver and
Paul Gray and I'm confident the
president vest will carry on that proud
tradition I know that Congress and the
administration look forward to working
closely with him in the years to come in
large measure the success of our nation
tomorrow will depend on the quality of
our investment today in higher education
and
scientific research the test for all of
us in the coming decade is to find
effective ways to broaden and deepen
that support I am confident that working
together we can meet this challenge and
meet it wirelessly and generously may
MIT prosper under Charles vest and
continue its outstanding record of
excellence in education
[Applause]
mr. chairman president vest and mrs.
vest
senator Kennedy members of the MIT
corporation faculty staff students
alumni and alumni of this prestigious
university honored yes esteemed
colleagues distinguished ladies and
gentlemen it is my very great pleasure
to bring greetings on this joyous
occasion
to president Chuck vest and the MIT
community which is eminently enriched by
his presence and his leadership I not
only extend my personal greetings but
those of the trustees faculty staff and
students of Lincoln University and more
than 100 other colleges and universities
serving historically or predominantly
african-american student bodies now as a
cultural anthropologist I cannot claim
extensive conversant with quantitative
methodologies but it does seem to me
that there is proof sway civ evidence
that if one wishes to become a college
or university president one of the
surest routes
is via a faculty or administrative
position at the University of Michigan
president vest is an excellent test case
but we can also point to among the
sitting presidents President Frank
Rhodes of Cornell president Harold
Shapiro of Princeton president Linda
Wilson of Radcliffe your humble servant
and of course the current president of
the University of Michigan Jim
Duderstadt who like his good friend
Chuck vest began his career in
Michigan's College of Engineering and
these financially lean years in higher
education perhaps Jim the University of
Michigan might give itself a boost by
levying a
exit tax on those faculty and
administrators whom it has prepared to
move into the lofty and not unluck
rative position of university president
but then when I think of Chuck vests
career at Michigan I would have to say
that he gave so much to that institution
that Michigan should have given him an
exit bonus for service above and beyond
the call of duty I remember Chuck vest
as a quiet force at the University of
Michigan a man who might be likened to a
laser moving through seemingly
impenetrable objects and obstacles with
precision and speed to get things done
Chuck was the architect and
administrator of the College of
Engineering programs to recruit retain
and graduate underrepresented minority
students and these programs in turn were
successful models for Michigan's other
schools and colleges as well as for
schools of engineering around the
country while others spoke of equity and
equality as a threat to excellence in
higher education Chuck vest and Jim
dudas get do two stat convincingly
proved that the pursuit of excellence
did not preclude a commitment to equity
indeed the success of the minority
students in Michigan's College of
Engineering proved that the pursuit of
excellence could be enhanced by the
intellectual and cultural diversity
brought to the University through
programs to provide equity and equality
for all the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology is fortunate to have at its
helm a man who understands as he said
today that an uncompromising commitment
to scholarly excellence is fully
compatible with the determination to
encourage and enable the blossoming of
talent among youth who have been
tradition
excluded from many of this country's
opportunities in higher education mr.
chairman I applaud the university's good
judgment and good fortune mr. president
as a colleague and as a friend I offer
my sincerest congratulations and I stand
ready with commiserations when the going
gets tough as it inevitably will for all
of us thank you
[Applause]
very quickly it's wonderful we now hear
from three folks who are members so to
speak of the of the inside MIT community
Stacy McGee ver a member of the class of
1993 and president of the undergraduate
Association will bring greetings from
undergraduate students michael Grossberg
graduate student in mathematics and
president of the graduate student
council will bring greetings from
graduate students and finally christian
jay matthew member of the class of 1943
president of the Alumni Association of
MIT alumni and alumnae and member
ex-officio of the institute's governing
board will bring greetings from the
graduates
[Applause]
I was actually hoping that more of you
would have left after dessert but since
you're still here on behalf of the
undergraduate Association of MIT I'd
like to bring greetings to Charles
Rebekah John and Kemper vest as well as
the rest of the distinguished guests to
present today would professor Ken
azari's requested that I bring that I
brought I bring greetings to president
vest my response was naturally yes a few
days later I received a memo to let me
know more details such as such as when
and where I should be and that the talk
should be about three minutes long I was
somewhat amused to see that the planners
of the events were optimistic things
were actually going to run according to
schedule my three minutes were specified
as 235 to 238 on the bulletin but what
the undergraduates have to say can't be
set in three minutes
furthermore the issues we want to
address require talking with people
rather than speaking to them
for these reasons I'm thankful that dr.
vest has been exceptionally responsive
to students over the past year
demonstrating a great willingness to
listen a concern for students and a
concern for the future of Education and
because I am an undergraduate I must
echo a concern which dr. vest mentioned
earlier today that the undergraduate
curriculum especially in engineering is
becoming more and more constrained
engineering students today need to draw
from a broader base of Sciences to learn
more advanced fields in technology to
develop a sense of ethics and product
integrity and while doing all of the
rest to develop as a human person
despite the fact that the amount of
information to learn has increased over
the past few decades mi t--'s curriculum
has remained essentially the same for
the past 30 years mit has a great
opportunity to define a new educational
paradigm for engineering education
even now the Institute faculty is
considering adding a biology requirement
to students already packed coursework
the rationale for doing so is well
justified that MIT should be giving
scientific literacy to its students in
order to prepare them for a lifetime of
learning but there are many concerns
both from students and faculty that
there simply isn't enough time to do it
all in four years there's a considerable
amount of discussion both at MIT and
elsewhere on whether or not engineering
should follow the lead of other
professions such as law and medicine and
expand to a five-year program this is
the uncertainty and to which we welcome
president fest I have confidence that
his enthusiasm for a redefinition of the
Institute's mission will guide MIT
through a crucial period in
undergraduate education and to echo the
words of dr. vest truly shaped the
future thank you
[Applause]
distinguished guests delegates and
faculty ladies and gentlemen on behalf
of the Graduate Student Council it is my
great pleasure to welcome the vest MIT
with the crucial role Science and
Technology has taken in our society can
we afford to ignore the culture from
which it comes the glitz and sparkle of
the high-tech makes it easy to forget
that science is done by people it's
wonderful that MIT has a new president
who seems to recognize the human element
in science for America to continue to
provide produce the highest quality
scientists and research we must provide
a healthy and positive atmosphere
graduate students are the future
researchers and educators president vest
recently told the story that he
surprised the government official while
discussing funding apparently the idea
that in the process of sponsoring
research the government was training
America's future of scientists and
engineers ie graduate students was
completely novel I recently read an
article summarizing mi t--'s book made
in America it explained that Japanese
companies often provide a healthy
environment by giving their workers some
degree over control of control over how
they work MIT is showing leadership in
in this area just this year for the
first time there are student members on
the committee's that recommend the
selection of deans two days ago I heard
about a graduate student who was told by
a faculty member that having a family
was entirely inappropriate he said I
don't pay you to raise kids I pay you to
do research it seems that rather we
should be encouraging exactly the kind
of humanistic people that would want to
raise a family and am i an MIT committee
recently studied this issue and dr. vest
seems very keen to address these
problems when I first spoke to president
vest he started by asking me about the
environment for women and minorities
which as you know has been a traditional
problem in science I am encouraged
because I believe that he is committed
to showing leadership in giving a human
face to the monolith of science I wish
the president the greatest success in
creating a healthy environment for
researchers and educators and I wish him
and his family many happy years in
Cambridge thank you
[Applause]
president vest chuck as president of the
association of alumni and alumni of MIT
it is my distinct privilege and pleasure
to extend to you Becky
Kemper and John a warm welcome to the
MIT family on this historic day our
association which now numbers over
90,000 loyal sons and daughters of MIT
located in 127 countries in addition to
the United States pledges its full
support in helping you achieve achieve
your vision for the future of MIT which
you shared with us in your inspirational
address this morning we know with
particular interest your observation
that MIT needs to redefine this mission
as the world changes rapidly about us
this observation together with your
thoughts about some of the issues facing
MIT and the opportunities as reported in
the recent issue of Technology Review
and in your talk this morning represents
a challenge to the entire Institute
family we are especially appreciative
that you have agreed to meet with our
clubs and to share these views with us
as you did so eloquently in Northern
California in January just three months
after taking office everywhere that I go
visiting alumni clubs around the company
country alumni and alumnae comment about
how rapidly you have come to understand
the complexities of this great
institution and its people your
willingness to assume national
leadership and speaking out on policy
issues and especially the importance of
science and technology and related
educational programs is commendable
we to share your concern that whereas in
the past great educational institutions
such as MIT were highly respected by
both the federal government and the
public this respect is changing if not
actually declining we welcome the
opportunity to support and serve you as
you face these challenges and leading
MIT to even greater heights of
accomplishment as an important national
and international resource we sincerely
hope that we will continue to earn the
compliment you paid us when you said the
constituency that gives the university
the greatest sense of hope and vitality
and enthusiasm is indeed its alumni and
alumnae here the largest segment of the
MIT family Chuck again our best wishes
for continued success in your
illustrious career as you undertake the
awesome responsibilities to which you
have dedicated yourself as the 15th
president of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology
[Applause]
greetings from our city and from a state
Alice K Wolf mayor of the city of
Cambridge to which the Institute moved
just 75 years ago this spring at the
specific invitation of the City Council
will bring greetings from our city James
J Duderstadt president of the University
of Michigan and a longtime close
colleague of president vest will bring
greetings from Michigan
[Applause]
mr. chairman president mrs. best the
best youngsters youngsters anymore young
people as mayor of the city of Cambridge
I want to welcome you to our city I want
to welcome you to this wonderful
institution that has such great
leadership qualities in our country and
in the world I bring you the greetings
of the Cambridge City Council and of the
96,000 people of the city of Cambridge
and I didn't know until today that you
and I have approximately the same number
of constituents mit has played a major
role in our country
plays a major role in our city I was
just saying that the many many companies
many many efforts incubate off this
campus into the neighborhood incubate
new and scientific adventures and many
new important discoveries for our
country and so as you come and you have
been here for this year we look forward
to your leadership in our community your
citizenship in our community and your
capacity to work with the city of
Cambridge in a productive manner at this
time I would like to read to you a very
brief resolution which the mayor has
brought to you whereas Charles M vest
has begun his tenure as the 15th
president of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology and whereas presidents
vest inauguration occurs at a time of
many changes for the city of Cambridge
and its University and whereas turning
points such as this are an ideal time to
forge new relationships
now therefore I Alice K Wolfe mayor of
the city of Cambridge on behalf from the
Cambridge City Council congratulate
Charles
vest on his inauguration as president of
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
with the expectation that the president
will bring great leadership to the
Institute and to a productive
partnership with the city of Cambridge
issued on this 10th day of May 1991 by
myself I'm very pleased to welcome you
to thank you for the year that you have
given us and to also present to you a
small momentum of appreciation from the
city a picture history of the city of
course coming from the MIT press and
with and with a with a picture in it
which you are not neither you nor I were
able to see a picture of the building of
MIT in 1915 thank you very much
[Applause]
distinguished guests colleagues
president and missus vest Chuck and
Becky Tuffy I got to tell you chuck that
Ann and I have been a bit nervous all
day long we've never been in so much
scarlet and gray before it feels a
little bit like Ohio but when the Sun
came out and we saw that that marvelous
sign above one of your buildings the
University of Michigan at Cambridge we
knew that our Michigan colony had been
re-established once again with Michigan
leadership of course you know this is
the second Michigan leader Jerry Wiesner
being the first at MIT Frank Rose
incidentally pointed out that the folks
that design that sign did it very
cleverly and very efficiently because we
can take it up the river one of these
days and also put it over another
building
[Applause]
of course I'm referring to Radcliffe the
Michigan of the east with Linda Wilson
as one of our former colleagues the RC
darkus have pointed out the number of
college presidents that have been rated
from the University of Michigan in fact
when Chuck was named president of MIT a
member of the press asked me why in the
best language of Operation Desert Storm
Michigan had become the mother of
university bureaucrats I thought about
it for a moment and it's clear that
we're kind of a boot camp for higher
education after where else can you be
faced with navigating the fierce and
bureaucratic labyrinths of higher
education dodging the deans firing squad
evading the foraging faculty not last in
the only Trotskyite student
demonstrators remaining on the face of
the planet passing political correctness
tests across the entire spectrum
learning the secret of town-gown
relationships through intense
negotiations with the People's Republic
of Ann Arbor being pilloried by the
Michigan daily as an enemy of the people
and in the same week by the Michigan
review for betraying Western
civilization facing the forces of
darkness lurking in our state
legislature soothing savage donors
surmounting the government audit of
flowers and liquor bills and I suppose
inauguration events eventually and
putting together a two and a half two
billion dollar budget after all of that
you're ready to take your place at any
of the battlements of higher education
for those who know him chuck vast may
seem to be a very unlikely survivor of
such a tough trial-by-fire
indeed to some of you who may seem like
an unlikely warrior all together modest
and soft-spoken a humane decent scholar
scientist slow to judge but quick to
defend the underdog a listener and our
land a learner Chuck might also appear
to be the last person to lead a charge
in the battle but I believe these
appearances are quite deceiving first of
all as I've noted he's already a
decorated veteran then too Chuck has a
zealous side I've never known anyone
with a more fierce sense of integrity a
more unwavering commitment
to justice or a more steady moral
courage is truly a man for all seasons
he's definitely the right man for this
place in this season when higher
education and science are both under
unprecedented hostile fire I promise you
MIT the scientific community American
higher education that all of us can look
to Chuck fest with easy confidence he
will be a vigorous perseverant and
victorious champion of our cause he will
be a voice of reason and integrity in
the halls of science and education as
well as in government and in public life
you'll learn the admiration and
affection of everyone here at MIT just
as he's done at Michigan when Chuck was
considering the possibility of moving to
MIT we used to talk a good deal about
this marvelous institution its
leadership in science and technology its
extraordinary faculty and student body
it's great tradition but of course there
were other attractive features the fact
that it had no law school no medical
school it didn't all award honorary
degrees and it had no revenue sports
although one of your colleagues told me
that in fact chess is rapidly becoming a
revenue sport at MIT since we realized
that Chuck and Becky while lured by
these characteristics will nevertheless
experience some withdrawal symptoms
we've arranged for a gradual transition
Chuck you should know that on September
7th we've arranged to bring the entire
University of Michigan football team to
Boston oh not to worry we're not going
to challenge MIT at least yet rather
we're going to challenge Boston College
across the Charles that's the warm-up
before the next week we have to face
Notre Dame and Florida State
back-to-back in Ann Arbor however in
keeping with the spirit of this occasion
I want to tell you that we expect to see
the maize and blue flags flying over the
president's house both at our colonies
at MIT and at Radcliffe and for that
reason
I brought one for Linda Wilson as well
we also expect to hear the strains of
the Michigan fight song within these
hallowed walls hail to the victors
valiant hail to chuck and becky vest
hail to the champions of the east
congratulations
[Applause]
it is now my privilege to invite Chuck
and Becky to come up here
I do not offer you equal time but an
opportunity to speak in your own defense
[Applause]
Thank You chairman gray senator Kennedy
Mary wolf
president Bach distinguished colleagues
family friends you'll be greatly
relieved to know that I am NOT going to
give a speech I just want to answer a
question that has been asked me over and
over in the days preceding this event
and also throughout this morning and
that was is there something that's
scaring you is there something you're
nervous about is there something that
you're worried about there were two
things and I will share them with you
candidly now the first was to recognize
that this morning I had to come to the
podium and Killian Court and accept what
is probably the greatest challenge in
American higher education a task that's
daunting a job that some people think is
so difficult as to be nearly impossible
and that of course was to follow Frank
Rhodes to the speaker's platform I
actually had something like that as the
beginning of my remarks but after
listening to Claude Kara's honest and
professor Tapscott and Paul Gray and
others I decided that there was so much
eloquence that you might not even get
the joke the second thing was an
apprehension that remained with me as a
deep anxiety until just five minutes ago
and that was what kind of retribution
Jim Duderstadt was going to bring to me
after the havoc that I wreaked upon him
at his inauguration fortunately it was
relatively mild Jim but seriously all we
really want to say is thank you it is an
unbelievably touching experience to
recognize that here in a single room we
have not only our new colleagues and
friends the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology an incredible group of
dignitaries who have come here today to
pay homage to this institution but also
people from literally every stage of our
lives there are people here today who
and
to grade school with me people who went
to college with us people who were part
of Aryan Arbor years as well as those
that we are beginning now in Cambridge
and I just cannot tell you what a thrill
it is that all of you are here I want to
say only that there are two other people
we wish very much we're here today and
of course my parents who are here in
spirit unable to make the trip but I did
talk to them on the telephone
immediately after the ceremony and they
know what's going on they've been
following the hours through the script
Mary and we're right on time so they
know exactly what's happening now but I
just want to thank all of you and
particularly those of you who I cannot
begin to enumerate who have given me so
much over the years and sent me on my
way to the task that Becky and I now you
know take upon ourselves it's a
wonderful opportunity it's literally as
I've told many people a call to national
service and we feel already a very
integral part of this warm and wonderful
community and we look forward to the
years ahead thank you very much
I won't add but just one second to
what's already been said here but I
would just like to say that in a job
like this especially the part that I
have that the love and the support of
family and friends both far and near is
so terribly important and I really
appreciate everyone who's come today to
celebrate this with us and I am counting
and looking forward to your continued
support thank you
[Applause]
as this luncheon draws to a close I
would like simply to express my
appreciation on behalf of the Institute
on behalf of its governing board to all
of those folks who joined in this
program today to bring special and very
personal greetings to Chuck and Becky
all of us here today have a sense of the
elements of encouragement of respect of
affection of support of love that is
represented here today and you have from
all of us our support and our good
wishes as you carry on with the
leadership of this institution this
inaugural luncheon is adjourned
thank you very much
you